at lumen field no longer century lane
field as of last night
lumen field the seahawks have never lost
peter
at lumen field what an accomplishment
carlos dunlap was the one guy who
doesn't fit with what we're used to
seeing
when we see seahawks coaches and players
he's the new guy
wanted out of cincinnati landed in
seattle and
had the game clinching sack preventing
kyler murray
from pulling a rabbit out of his hat or
elsewhere last night
to force overtime or maybe maybe i had a
feeling if they scored they were gonna
go for two we'll never know
but exciting game the cardinals would
not go away
but the seahawks avoiding a three-game
losing streak and
seemingly figuring out peter how to
contain
kyla murray good morning by the way it's
pft live and peter can you do me a favor
i did a little touch-up of my sideburns
beforehand if i
like if the die streaks down my face
will you let me know so that would be
very embarrassing if that would happen
mike i love the way how you sneak in
comments
about our democracy
i just love it i just thought it would
be
embarrassing if the die that i put in my
sideburns would be
running down my face during the show and
i would appreciate it if you would tell
me because apparently when that happens
they don't always tell you so just would
you tell me hey listen
listen mike if my gray die uh
sort of seeps down my face why don't you
tell me that too
good morning good morning the biggest
thing i
thought last night the biggest thing i
thought
midway through the second half this was
even before
uh you know the big sack by carlos
dunlop at the end think of this mike
you know john schneider the gm of the
seahawks
uh acquired obviously acquired jamal
adams to bolster the secondary
acquired damon harrison uh who everybody
thought was retired
to bolster the run defense and then
acquired carlos dunlop and stupid me i
was saying
go get ryan kerrigan and i think they
did try to get ryan kerrigan but the
price was too high
uh you know with washington but
last night seattle was different
mike on defense than it has been all
season
now some people might say well okay uh
it looks like kyler murray might have a
sore arm so maybe he's not the same
that wasn't it it was the fact that now
finally the seattle defense can force
the action after jamal adams is back
from his groin injury
and after carlos dunlop comes in
i mean he's got three and a half sacks
in three games
he's already been worth the mike how
about
how about how about this they paid a
seventh round pick and a backup guard
for carlos dunlop it's you know john
schneider
this just in he knows what he's doing
yeah i mean look at that seven games
with cincinnati one sack three games
with seattle now three and a half sacks
a guy that they acquired
prior to the trade deadline and he has
paid dividends
to me peter there's one very short
sequence
that summed up the night for the
cardinals offense
and the seattle defense the score is
23-21
the seahawks have the ball deep in their
own
end but not pressed up against the goal
line yet on that first play
when jamal adams busts through and they
had a screen that was designed and
dan arnold i think it was chipped the
defensive
end but he kind of got twisted around
and jamal adams came
flying in forced the issue and it may
have been atoms that he
chipped who went by him adams just
screwed everything up
kyler murray had to throw the ball when
arnold wasn't turned looking for it and
i don't know what kyler was thinking it
clearly was going
to be intentional grounding it was one
of those where the ball's nowhere near
he could have gotten it at least
close to the feet of the intended
receiver
and that intentional grounding moved
them back to the two and then you get
holding in the end zone and it may not
have been
holding in the end zone the hold started
it appeared
out of the end zone that's something
mike pereira pointed out last night on
the broadcast
and that results in the safety and it's
2521
seahawks why and we you know i complain
about this all the time when it doesn't
happen we need to praise it when it does
happen the seahawks taking the play
clock all the way down to zero
on the drive where they eventually right
the field goal to make it 28-21
leaving the cardinals with as little
time as possible genius coaching
by the seahawks to do that because that
gets lost in this shuffle far too
often you know anybody who plays madden
understands the value of taking the
clock all the way down to zero the
seahawks pulled that off last night
and and put the eggs in that one last
basket of a drive that they were able to
shut the door on the cardinals
eventually it looked for a while like
the cardinals might score
but eventually they slammed the door
mike you're right i was thinking the
same thing last night
uh you know when i and i looked it up
this morning 12 plays
37 yards
and they took seven minutes and so that
was the whole idea
the whole idea is not to say hey let's
be explosive
and and and if you're not going to give
it away if you can get dk metcalf deep
i get it but the idea was
to try to score and to try to give the
ball
back to arizona with next to no time
left now
arizona did have enough time left but
clearly
what happened on this play is that you
know like i said the
the the acquisitions at the end carlos
dunlop
goes around kelvin beach him around
arizona's right side
and you know i thought last night
i'm not sure and and the broadcast was
very big on there's something
going on with kylo murray's shoulder and
the wincing it sure made it seem like
that
but the other thing about kyler murray
last night is that
he wasn't quite as elusive
as he has been in other games now maybe
that's the quickness
of the seattle front i don't know
and i'd love to be able to watch that
again to just see but to me
he wasn't the incredible weapon
that he's been in a lot of games this
year
well there was one play in particular
that the cheese was not taken
on the read option and he could not get
away
on a on a third and short i believe it
was and then when he got the ball down
near the goal
kj wright just nailed him yeah and
and and you know what in hindsight he
probably should have handed off because
chase edmonds could have just popped it
right through for the first down
uh and he just made a bad decision and
kj wright made a very good decision
to stay home and then when kyler murray
tries to run in for what would have been
a record
sixth game in a row with a rushing
touchdown they just bottled him up he
couldn't even get
started and i think maybe they've
figured out and it'll be interesting to
see whether other teams can duplicate
this
you just can't let him get started once
he gets started
he's gone you've got to get him
before that first step before he gets
that that
zip and he's got and he's just and you
have no chance
and that's what they were able to do
last night i mean yeah 15 rushing yards
we're talking about the arm and the
shoulder
i and i don't know if he's maybe a
little banged up
right short week right you know i i
yeah he wasn't listed on the injury
report at all it'll be interesting to
see if he is next week
with whatever it was that was bothering
in the first half i think maybe he had a
little visit from dr needle at halftime
that kept him from wincing in the second
half frankly
but uh yeah something wasn't right with
kyle murray last night he wasn't the guy
that you know we've been elevating and
elevating i know i've been as guilty as
anyone of
into this guy who's in the upper echelon
of all nfl quarterbacks he wasn't that
guy
last night mike you talked about
uh five rushes for 15 yards which is
stark
obviously and you talked about the two
runs where
he chose himself you know
rather than i think it was chase edmonds
and chase edmonds it might have been
kenyan drake i forget
the you're talking about the play where
he went around right end and thought he
could sneak it in
and he had three guys basically waiting
for him to escort him out of bounds
but that just showed me last night that
kyler murray
really trusts himself
and i would too if i were him but last
night he trusted himself
twice when he should have given the ball
off
and again look it's easy in hindsight to
say that but i think when he watches the
tape of this game
i mean he is not kyler murray is in no
way a selfish guy
okay but last night he trusted himself
when he should have trusted his
teammates and i'm sure
that when they sit down and watch that
you know in the next few days or monday
or tuesday whenever it is
they will he and cliff kingsbury will
say you know
i gotta i gotta give it up a little bit
more and he should have last night
here's calla murray from after the game
on the missed opportunities that the
cardinals offense had
got our chances we just didn't know we
didn't play well enough to win the game
just really shooting ourselves in the
foot i mean
you know it wasn't a clean game by me
you know
easier said than done to play those but
that's just
got to be better you know
say it every week you know try to give
ourselves the best possible chance to
win the game and that's
that's uh that doesn't help you
he also said as to the potential or a
parent shoulder or arm injury i'm good
and you know i you usually see a guy
still in his pads at a press conference
after the game after a win like you know
you just want to savor the moment
i just i can't help but wonder whether
he just didn't want to go through the
potential agony
of getting his shoulder pads and his
jersey off if
if he truly he clearly was bothered by
something
he clearly was now they may have done
something at halftime to numb the pain
but uh
that that's going to be a fascinating
wednesday when the injury report comes
out what will be on there
for kyler murray will there be anything
they got the patriots coming up next so
it's not like they can take a breath
here
you know one of the things we were
talking about yesterday you look at how
all those teams are bunched up at the
top of the nfc
somebody's going to fall off somebody's
going to miss the playoffs right
somebody's going to be pissed off
because they're going to finish 10-6
9-7 while the nfc east champion hosts
a a playoff game with a sub 500 record
and last night's game was huge in that
regard peter what a difference
to be between seven and three and six
and four in the nfc
so like i said it doesn't get any easier
for the cardinals they got to pick up
the pieces and figure out how to go
handle uh even though the patriots are
down they're still the patriots they
still have bill belichick and
he's going to have some film now he can
use to come up with a way to slow down
that offense
two points mike i've said it for the
last couple of weeks ever since the new
york giants had a pulse
tom brady and his old friends
the new york giants who ruined his
season
in 2007 and 2011
and now a new era of giants out to ruin
tom brady's latest adventure
but but secondly i i would just say this
that
that really is interesting to me about
the nfl schedule you know
mike when we look at the schedule in
april
do we ever say well geez uh
they're playing the patriots but they
never we never say
when you're playing a team and you know
the arizona cardinals would have been so
much better off
if they had at foxborough at east
rutherford in the span of 15 days
if that happened in early october rather
than
uh november and early december or
whenever it is
and because i think what you're going to
see now
you're going to see two games neither of
which
are going to be either easy or i mean i
my guess right now i think the cardinals
will probably go one and one in those
two games i don't know
how i don't know what they win what they
lose but
those are both teams that have gotten
significantly better
in the last few weeks so the schedule
does not
favor the arizona cardinals yeah i agree
with you completely the schedule does
favor the seattle seahawks who ended
that two-game losing streak and now are
back in control
temporarily of the nfc west the rams
have something to say about that on
monday night when they play the
buccaneers
the seahawks were desperate to get some
balance back into their offense here's
russell wilson and pete carroll from
after the game on their ability
to do so we had a lot of amazing runs
and that that controls the game
we got to a lot of checks a lot of plays
you know changed the plays a bunch and
got to
some really cool runs and coach shotty
and i were on it all day just
communicating i thought he called a
great game we made it challenging for
their defense
it felt like seahawks you know felt like
the seahawks that we've all seen over
the years
carlos did a great job tonight he did
exactly what we needed he
we needed him to run hard and run tough
knock people backwards and
and make extra yards with with you know
his juice and uh the guys up front
responded with them you know i know we
had
80 yards or something like that um that
was a really good contribution to this
this effort tonight and it balanced us
out just like we talked about
russ didn't have to throw for 400 yards
to have a big night he had a big night
thrown for you know just under 200.
yeah they had carlos hyde back which was
huge statistically
for the seahawks look at that balance
between passing and rushing 182
165 pass rush respectively
the balance was not there for the
arizona cardinals and between carlos
hyde
and dj dallas who flashed a couple of
times both scarborough
who i didn't even know was on a team
frankly until last night but that's what
happens when you're
digging down to the bottom of the depth
chart and finding who you can to put in
uniform they hope to get chris carson
back next game they
hope to get rashad penny first round
pick from a couple of years ago
back later in the year they could be
firing on all cylinders at the right
time but that's what they need it can't
be
out of whack it can't be just russell
wilson
all the time it becomes too predictable
anytime an offense peter is one
dimensional
it becomes easier for that offense to be
stopped and
this is what they're trying to get to
and if they can play like they did last
night offensively on a regular basis
then you know that that dip was
temporary and they'll be right back at
the top of the conference
before too long you know what i think
last night proved also mike that
there's so much focus i mean i don't
think fox went five minutes last night
with telling us something
without telling us something about dk
metcalf he clearly has become
the media's focus for every game he's a
great player we all know that
but i had the feeling last night mike
that here over in the corner is this
little guy hey
my name is tyler lockett and you know
what i'm really really good
i am the reincarnation of doug baldwin
and you can't win without me
and that's why i mean and again i
understand how a the media works i
understand how
defenses work everybody says we gotta
stop
dk metcalf but the key is
this receiving core right now reminds me
a little bit of minnesota's mike
in that you know just when you thought
that adam thielen is probably going to
get blanket a little bit too much
all of a sudden now a young kid justin
jefferson
just 21 years old is one of the 10 best
receivers in football
walking into the nfl and dk metcalf is
like that too
even though obviously he's a year been
in the year league a year longer
so to me i think the
depth relatively speaking at receiver
that the seahawks have right now means
that if you get a guy blanketed or
if a defense really concentrates on
metcalf
russell wilson is probably going to say
hey i am absolutely totally fine
with going to tyler locket and last
night
nine targets nine catches you know a
pesky little touchdown he had in the
corner of the end zone
when patrick peterson made a horrible
move
to try to i think shadow
two receivers at the same time which uh
i don't think you can do and you're
right about dk metcalf yesterday espn
launched a multi-platform
focus and feature on dk metcalf and it
was a great article and i learned some
things about it i didn't realize he was
told in 2018 by doctors for example he
may never play again after he suffered
the broken
bone in his neck and he really has
become
the darling but tyler lockett who had a
knee injury that
kept him from practicing tuesday limited
him on wednesday he was questionable for
the game
he ended up having a great performance
and and they got
metcalfe more involved he had the first
touchdown of the game he only had 46
receiving yards but it was his best
night ever against the cardinals
peter chris sims and i have been arguing
all week that brian schottenheimer needs
to expand the playbook
to just get the ball in metcalf's hands
we only saw that
once there was a receiver screen that
went nowhere
because the blocking was horrible and i
hope they don't just tear that play up
because they tried it once and it didn't
work i want to see
receiver screens to metcalf i want to
see jet sweeps i want to see him lined
up in the backfield
or at least pretending to go to the back
field and then rolling back away like a
tyreek hill
this guy is a weapon and you can't just
have him run down the field and try to
get open
yeah i think you're right mike i you
know i i come away from
seahawks games sometimes saying to
myself you know and last night okay
metcalf touches it three times
you know you come away saying you've got
to be more imaginative to get the ball
in his hands
and i'd like to see him i think the
reason
why most teams maybe don't overuse
the jet sweep when it looks like you
know remember when percy harvin used to
run that we used to say oh my god
what in the world where did he come from
but
i think that it's it's also
you know one of these things it's almost
like a punt return sometimes
you know do you want to put your guy you
know
in that sort of in in harm's way that
way
and so that's why i think they probably
don't do enough of it
but to me it's hard to come out of a
game
saying we only got dk metcalf the ball
three times
greg olson ended up in the blue medical
tent
when he was unable to put any weight in
his left foot he's got a
ruptured plantar fascia in his left foot
he's likely done for the year and he's
likely done for good this was that one
last year he was going to play before he
enters the fox
broadcast booth he already has a deal to
do so that's been a long-standing report
from the new york post
it was sad to see that happen and i i
just i had a feeling as soon as he went
down and they went out of their way to
not speculate
they wouldn't even say looks like his
foot's injured it's like guys i know
you're not supposed to give a diagnosis
but
clearly it's something below the knee uh
on one of his legs and it's okay to
acknowledge that and it did look
serious and it is serious and i feel bad
for greg olsen especially if this team
really turns it around he wanted to be
part
of potential championship team he got
close a few years ago with carolina
but it looks like he he is at the the
end of the road which
you know he's had a great long career he
was a first round pick of the bears back
in 2007
but it feels like and it looks like this
may be it peter
yeah i mean seattle's lucky mike in my
opinion anyway
you might not say that jacob hollister
and will disley
are going to make anybody quake they're
not gonna make any defensive coordinator
quake right now
but i do think mike that those guys
have been with russell wilson now for
two plus years
and in my opinion you at least
have guys who've played in big games
who've been in your system
and here you're going to be able to use
russell wilson's not going to shy away
from going to those guys
i do feel for olson olsen is uh
olson's one of my favorite guys in the
league uh
he's always reachable always available
you know i remember this spring i was
talking to him
and i said why did you why'd you choose
to go
why did you choose to go for one more
year rather than
uh to go right to tv and he said
you know this is a family adventure
you know will we ever have an
opportunity the rest of our lives
to live somewhere far away from what we
consider home which is the carolinas
and we're looking at it as a family
adventure put the kids in a new school
and and be able to do a lot of different
things in a new city now
i don't know what covet has done to that
but that's the kind of guy yeah
different kind of it's not about yeah
where am i going to be able to get the
most
catches it's hey seattle's a really cool
place let's go live there for a year
i love that and and i think he
and his wife i i think they have this
spirit about them
let's experience stuff that football can
give us
and let's go play for a really fun team
i mean i don't know about you but last
night after the game when you see
pete carroll leap into carlos dunlap's
arms
i said carlos dunlap just got here 10
minutes ago
and the coach is already treating him
like hey you want to go have a sleepover
you know he's just here pete carroll is
hilarious and so i think
i think guys like playing for that team
it is amazing to see it's almost like a
ponce de leon
fountain of youth transformation every
time pete carroll is anywhere near a
football field he moves
better he seems 20 years younger and
he loves every second of it and he had
to love it last night peter we talked
about balance on offense
the broader bigger picture balances
offense and defense and that had been
out of whack all year two
for the seahawks but now the defense
is stepping up this is the kind of game
when they do what they
did to an offense that was
the toast of the league after the hail
murray on sunday when they do
that and shut down the run game and and
you know handle deandre hopkins they
didn't shut him down you're never going
to shut him down
i'm still stunned and flabbergasted that
kyler murray was throwing to guys like
andy isabella
with the game on the line and not
deandre hopkins and maybe that last play
was going to deandre hopkins if he
wouldn't have been sacked by carlos
dunlap but
but the seahawks defense which we had
basically concluded was a shadow of what
it used to be
at least for one night it looked a
little like what it used to be
that's it and i think it was the imports
who helped do it
or who helped did it uh i think
one of the things that was really
interesting to me
did you notice that kj wright and bobby
wagner
it was like they had a little bit of the
fountain of youth last night too
those guys are irreplaceable pieces
right now at the center of that defense
but i think they have been sort of
looking at the front office and saying
are you kidding me is this all we got
and so that's why i praised john
schneider
for basically in the span of six months
you know going out and getting
uh jamal adams snacks harrison
and obviously carlos dunlop because
those guys
also made bobby wagner and kj wright
more energetic and play significantly
better last night
well we were all reminded that the
seahawks are one of the elite teams in
the nfl they're not going anywhere
they're not ready to yield
anything to the upstart cardinals they
got
a measure of revenge for the cardinals
beating them last year
at what was centurylink field with a
crowd there
last night with no one there and a new
name the seahawks got it
done hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports